let's go next to Sammy from New York
City people really shot out of a cannon
uh great to hear people getting right
into their questions Sammy welcome
hey David I hope you can hear me I can
hear you beautifully oh good
um so yeah um sounds like things did
better
um last night than we kind of expected
and I listened to your uh a live stream
that was awesome as usual my question is
and I just tuned in so I hope
um someone else didn't ask this but my
thought is
um Trump's gonna uh announce something
on November 15th but I feel like he's
gonna wait he wanted to wait in that
announced right away uh because
um he felt like
um let's just see like how all of these
elections turn out and if things are all
like in his favor then he would announce
um that he was gonna run and what do you
think or is that so I had that idea as
well but the thing is he's put on he's
put so much weight and made it so
obvious he plans to announce on Tuesday
that even though a bunch of the people
he picked lost I don't know that he can
go back on his word at this point in
time you know there's some Republicans
who are saying Trump's time is over what
he should do on the 15th is say I'm not
running and endorse Rhonda Santos that's
what would be best for the Republican
Party Trump's a huge narcissist and so
it's very hard for me to imagine that
he's going to do that
yeah yeah well that's true too but the
other thing is like when he when he
would say things like oh I have like I'm
gonna you know I have a better uh
insurance plan than Obamacare yeah
um and it's coming in two weeks like
everything's like it's coming it's
coming so I don't know yeah I think he
will announce I don't think this is like
the health care plan and then it'll be
interesting to see if and how the
polling shifts and if it's true that
it's Trump's for the taking or if the
betting markets are right that DeSantis
has a shot at this thing if he wants it
the problem for desantises yeah Trump
can announce Tuesday and that's fine
DeSantis just got re-elected Governor
right he can't look good if he announces
a run for the presidency any time in the
next six eight or even 10 months uh yeah
so I think that that's a limitation for
DeSantis me too and even like on on the
the Florida debate when when DeSantis
was asked look are you you know tell the
Florida people like
um you're gonna
um
yeah yeah and he wouldn't answer he
looked like a deer in the headlights he
did he he seemed to malfunction and
freeze up yeah no we'll see that that's
a complication for DeSantis how does he
smoothly transition into that yeah and
you know David um the last time we spoke
um I said you know how amazing I think
you are and and I really you have really
turned me on to politics like I wouldn't
be listening to all of these other um
debates if it wasn't for you like live
streaming and I I really appreciate that
because well I appreciate that very much
that's why we're doing it hopefully to
get people engaged yeah and like we all
have to be
um we we have to know what's going on we
have to be informed right
um and to make the right decisions and
and I know you asked me if I was
subscribed to the YouTube channel I'm
subscribed to all three I love it Sammy
thank you so much for the call I
appreciate it of course yeah yeah have a
good day David thank you there is the
great Sammy from New York City with some
very very positive statements that's for
sure
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your and and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below